hey 42 here inside the burning heart of
the Sun is the most powerful power plant
in our solar system an awesome massive
plasma at 15 million degrees Celsius it
is so hot and under such immense
pressures that the Sun's core is the
most perfect environment in our solar
system for a remarkable reaction to
happen
nuclear fusion at the center of all
atoms is a nucleus that has a positive
charge usually when two nuclei collide
they repel and bounce off each other
like two positive ends of a magnet
inside the Sun however the nuclei are
being compressed together under such
immense pressures and high temperatures
that they have nowhere else to go
the power of their repulsion is too weak
to overcome the overbearing force so
usually they do the only thing they can
do combined and so the two nuclei fuse
hence nuclear fusion creating the larger
atom in the Sun this is usually hydrogen
atoms fusing to become helium atoms
nuclear fusion causes the Sun to burn
away 4.3 million tons of mass per second
the equivalent of exploding four
trillion her Ashima bombs every second a
byproduct of this is energy and lots of
it it radiates from the Sun and bathes
our solar system in light and life
without this reaction occurring
ceaselessly as it has done for 4.6
billion years the Sun would die and so
would all life we know now what if we
could create our own miniature Sun here
on earth well that's exactly what
scientists all over the world are
currently trying to do simulating
nuclear fusion in a controlled
environment by creating a fusion reactor
could supply planet Earth with unlimited
clean energy for the rest of humanity's
existence and it gets better the only
fuel needed is plain old seawall
see water happens to be rich in
deuterium one of the most ideal hydrogen
isotopes needed for nuclear fusion and
there is enough sea water to power our
planet for two billion years fusion has
huge benefits over nuclear fission
fission is the process of splitting
atoms used by our current nuclear
reactors fusion is significantly cleaner
than fission there is almost no nuclear
waste to speak of the amount of energy
produced is also incomparable using
equal quantities of fuel fusion releases
at least four million times the energy
of burning coal and at least four times
the energy efficient
just a tiny half a gram of hydrogen fuel
produces 500 megawatts of electricity
Fusion produces no greenhouse gases only
helium which is inert but what if it all
goes up in flames
surely Chernobyl would look like a tea
party compared to a meltdown it's a
fusion reactor after all it is
simulating the Sun and the Sun is a big
and scary fireball well actually no
fission is a chain reaction nuclear
power plants are essentially harboring
it controls nuclear bomb if we lose
control then the chain reaction takes
over and boom fusion is the complete
opposite in the event of a meltdown or
other accidents there would be no chain
reaction it's hard enough to create the
perfect conditions for fusion to happen
in the first place so if anything did go
awry then the conditions would no longer
be right for fusion to occur and the
reaction would almost immediately stop
fusion then it seems is one of those
rare things in life that is all pros
without a single cob it truly is the
holy grail of energy production so why
aren't we building them everywhere well
there is currently one rather large con
we can't bloody do it
fusion requires the most perfect
conditions to take place I mean it is
like trying to create the Sun in
miniature on planet earth inside a box
that's not going to be easy the
frustrating thing about fusion is that
we know for sure it is possible
Einstein's theory of relativity sorted
that realization 100 years ago attempts
to create a fusion reactor began in the
40s
you've probably heard all about them and
how fusion energy is only 30 years away
well they told us that in the 40s and
then again 30 years later they proclaim
the same thing yet again in fact there
is a pervasive joke amongst the
scientific community that fusion energy
will always be just 30 years away is
this really true is unlimited clean
energy only a pipe dream that we can
never realize well maybe not amazingly
scientists have already done it there
are two primary types of fusion reactor
design one invented by Russian
scientists is called the tokamak this is
a large torus surrounded by powerful
electromagnets the torus is filled with
fuel which is heated up by the
electromagnets and thus becomes a super
hot plasma and when I say hot I mean
fake in hearts the plasma must reach a
hundred and fifty million degrees
Celsius before fusion can be achieved
tokamak show immense promise for
achieving successful fusion on earth but
it is far from easy
for example the plasma mustn't touch the
walls of the container if it does then
it cools down too fast and fusion can't
happen the second design called inertial
confinement fusion consists of a very
large football with the walls lined with
the world's most powerful lasers no one
fortunately we aren't trying to build a
desktop a tiny pellet of the fuel the
size of a peppercorn is placed in the
center of the container and at precisely
the same time the lasers all fire
striking the pellet from every angle
simultaneously
if successful the pellet has no choice
but to implode creating huge
temperatures and immense pressures
perfect conditions for the atoms within
the fuel pellet to fuse together the
first design has been successful in 1997
the jet tokamak reactor in Oxford
successfully produced 16 megawatts of
power output great so what's the holdup
well they had to use 24 megawatts of
heating to run the experiment a net loss
of energy which rather contradicts the
point of power production scientists
have a neat symbol for the ratio of
power used in an experiment compared to
the amount of power it produces q if an
experiment achieves a key worth one it
has broke even on power consumption and
output when a queue of more than one is
achieved nuclear fusion will be a viable
means of power production the jet
reactor produced a queue of 0.67 but a
new joint project in southern France
backed by the EU India Japan Korea
Russia China and the u.s. called
eater thinks it has the final solution
eita claims it will create the first
true star on our planet and the
absolutely huge reactor they are
creating several times the size of jet
is predicted to achieve a queue of 10 so
for every megawatt they put into it 10
megawatts of clean energy will be
produced so they say it sounds fantastic
until you learn that Ito won't even be
turned on until 2025 and it's only a
proof-of-concept it will never produce
energy for civilians if it works it's
estimated that it will be a further ten
years after eater
before fusion energy power plants are
available for real-world usage so that
could be 2035 or even 2050
since bureaucracy often delays such
projects immensely perhaps fusion is yet
another 30 years away
after all don't get me wrong Itza is an
essential and amazing project and quite
a feat of political collaboration too
but in 30 years a lot can happen the
population is going to balloon even more
energy needs will skyrocket with China
and emerging powers like India on the
rise and an awful lot more fossil fuel
is going to be consumed but you see I
think fusion energy is a lot lot closer
than that
for one major reason private industry
just look at how ridiculously wealthy
the current oil and gas companies are
the company that is the first to crack
commercially viable nuclear fusion is
going to generate immense investment and
wealth
not to mention political and military
power that's exactly why the world's
largest defense contractor Lockheed
Martin is currently developing a compact
fusion reactor that could be carried
inside a van and power an entire city
but it's not just the big boys there are
literally hundreds of startups worldwide
that are racing to be the first to bring
nuclear fusion to the masses some claim
within the next ten years three of the
most ambitious private enterprises are
canada-based
general fusion who have designed a
unique steam-powered piston reactor that
works along a similar principle to
record combustion engine Amazon CEO Jeff
Bezos is a big fusion proponent he has
invested millions into general fusion
tokamak energy in the UK that aims to
produce more compact tokamaks and
commonwealth fusion systems in the u.s
which has the same goal to create a
compact reactor with competition comes
progress especially competition amongst
well-funded private entities the entry
of private companies into the realm of
space travel has proven that but what
makes all these attempts so different to
the many that have come over the past
century that promised nuclear fusion
within the next thirty years well this
time it really is different all those
previous attempts may not have proved
beautiful but they were by no means
wasted they provided the world with
invaluable research most world altering
discoveries and inventions over history
did not originate from lightbulb moments
in which a scientist wakes up one day
and has a game-changing revelation some
perhaps but most of them were the result
of cumulative research over many decades
or centuries by hundreds of different
scientists all over the world building
upon the scientific papers and research
from their peers and predecessors the
best example of this cumulative research
is in your pocket no not that why do you
have that in your pocket
I'm talking about your smartphone this
device less than a centimeter thick has
more computing power than all of NASA's
computers put together when they put man
on the moon and it only exists because
of decades of small but meaningful
incremental improvements many thousands
of them in fusion the rate of these
small discoveries is increasing rapidly
helped in part by improved AI just take
a look at this chart of the number of
fusion related discoveries over the past
50 years
we know fusion works the Sun has proven
that and there will come a point perhaps
very soon when all these small
incremental improvements reach a
critical mass and positive G fusion will
finally be achieves when that happens
the world will quickly become a very
different place but how well there are
obvious environmental benefits to
finally having a reliable abundant clean
energy source some scientists think that
fusion energy could be humanity's sole
savior from destroying our own planet
through global warming
according to some of the more
pessimistic predictions out there if we
don't crack nuclear fusion within the
next 30 years humanity could be doomed
but something that is far more tangible
and certain is that nuclear waste would
stop being produced current nuclear
fission power keeps our modern world
ticking over it's far more reliable than
the alternatives and today it is
actually safer than renewable energy
seriously look it up but it does have a
deadly by-product that we still don't
quite know how to store safely in a way
that may not harm future generations
but beyond living in a cleaner world the
unlimited energy that Fusion would bring
into the world would change earth
forever electricity costs would plummet
meaning that developing countries would
be able to steam ahead and well develop
like never before
such nations would finally have access
to energy hungry applications such as
advanced water treatment something that
after the initial costs of being covered
energy would become so cheap it would be
just handed out to all citizens by some
nations almost like a human brains with
unlimited energy space exploration could
accelerate astronomically imagine being
able to send the large man spacecraft
into the depths of space that had an
onboard fusion reactor multiple
generations could live and die aboard
this craft without it needing to ever
return to Earth back on earth the scale
of projects would reach previously
unforeseen horizons with unlimited power
sci-fi dreams like floating cities on
the water city's huge theme parks and
resorts in the desert underwater and in
the frozen wastes of Antarctica would
all become financially feasible once we
have developed all the ancillary
technology now you may not necessarily
want a huge theme park in the desert and
these are obviously no more than
senseless ramblings from my brain it may
not happen like this but change would
happen on a tremendous scale
the important lesson here is not to give
up on impossible dreams the very fact
that humanity is still striving to
better itself whether it be fusion
energy or medical advances is a
remarkable thing indeed when we are
being bombarded 24/7 by news of climate
change and impending doom one should
never fail to underestimate the resolve
and the ingenuity of the human spirit
thanks for watching I've recently
launched my first book which I'm
crowdfunding stick a flagon is a
thousand years of bizarre history from
Britain and beyond the crowdfunding
campaign has reached one hundred percent
so it's definitely going to be published
thanks so much to everyone who has
already pledged but there are still some
stretch goals to reach so if you want to
get your hand on a first edition signed
copy then head on over to unbound watch
the launch video if you haven't already
and plus today thank you